[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
HEATHER CASSANO: Hi.
Can you all hear me?
OK.
All right.
So before I start,
I just want to do
a quick survey of the room
to find out how many of you
are designers, UX people?
Anybody?
Oh, good.
I see some hands.
And I think I know this,
because I saw the coding.
But how many of
you are engineers?
OK.
Lots of women.
Yay.
And then, other things.
Curious as to what they are.
Can you guys throw it out there?
What else?
AUDIENCE: Product management.
HEATHER CASSANO:
Product management.
AUDIENCE: Project management.
Data science.
HEATHER CASSANO: Say that again.
AUDIENCE: Data science.
HEATHER CASSANO: Data science.
AUDIENCE: All of the above.
HEATHER CASSANO:
All of the above.
Awesome.
OK, great.
Well, welcome.
I'm so excited to be
talking to you all.
This is a special presentation
for me for two reasons.
One is I'm very used to
getting up and talking
about user experience design.
It's my passion.
It's my career and my field.
I'm not going to talk
much about it today.
But I do want to
say the books that
are on your seats are basically
the most fabulous user
experience method
that I think we have,
which would be-- at Google, we
call it Google Design Sprints.
Very similar to the lighting
method that I'm used to using.
And they're not
even released yet.
So you guys are getting them
before they hit the press,
which will be next week.
So read them and enjoy.
Secondly, some of my
family is back here.
They actually came
here to support me.
[APPLAUSE]
And they told me not
to point them out,
so now they're going
to be mad at me.
And I also want to
say, I love being
surrounded by women in tech.
We don't have enough of them.
We need more, so I'm
so excited to see you.
My husband and I were just
standing back there a little
while ago and he said,
this is so weird.
I'm like the only guy here.
And I was like,
welcome to my world.
So I'm really excited
to have you all here.
OK.
So today, what I'm going
to talk about-- and again,
I've never really done
a presentation before
about me and my career.
So bear with me, first time.
I'm going to talk about
something, which I'm calling
white elephant opportunities.
So I was trying
to think of a way
to describe a little
bit of the path
that I've taken in my career--
for good and for bad--
and hope that it might help you.
So how many of you have heard
of white elephant parties?
Some of you.
Oh, good.
OK, a good chunk.
Because I've been
asking all week
with my team and
people are like,
I don't know what that is.
I'm like, uh-oh.
So a white elephant party,
in case you don't know,
is a party where
you get invited.
You bring a gift,
and then there's
like-- it's also called a Yankee
swap for those New Englanders
in the room.
And there's usually kind of
a gift that nobody wants,
or some gifts that nobody wants.
And then it's a game where
you kind of like-- you can
trade the gifts and you barter.
And you try to
get the good ones.
And the ones that you don't
want are called white elephants.
In preparation for
this talk, I actually
looked up, where
did that come from?
And it came from the King
of Thailand, back many,
many centuries ago, used to give
white elephants to the people
that he did not like.
And the reason that he did
was because they were sacred.
It was a religious symbol.
And so they were very
valuable in a way,
but they were not
allowed to do any work.
So when you received
a white elephant,
you had to care for it
for the rest of its life,
but it couldn't do
anything for you.
So that's where it came from.
So anyways, I thought I
would use that as an analogy
to opportunities that come
along that are kind of unique.
And that maybe you
should not resist.
So I'm going to talk a
little bit about that.
So what is a white
elephant opportunity?
So for me, it's an
opportunity that
presents itself to you that
might not be obvious to you.
It might be something
that scares you.
That you feel like, I
would never do that.
I can't do that.
That's like way too much for me.
It's something that in
addition to those things
will attract you for some
maybe mysterious reason.
Like, huh.
But it seems kind of cool.
I wish I was one of
those people that
could do that kind of thing.
And you may fail at a
white elephant opportunity.
And that's actually
a good thing.
So I'm going to talk a little
bit about how some of those
came for me.
So some of you may have
seen this drawing before.
So this is kind of what
people think about when
they think about success.
And you may have in
your heads right now--
and I know I did
many years back,
and even today-- you have
this kind of line in your head
like, I'm going to do this,
and then this, and then this,
and then I'm going
to be successful.
Yay.
That's not how it works.
So success really, first
of all, is something
that you personally define.
It's something that
is very unique to you.
And it's going to only work when
you feel that it works for you.
And it's something that
you find on your own.
Secondly, being successful is
about choosing the right path
and the right journey.
And the path of success
usually does look a little bit
like the squiggly line.
It's funny because
in design-- this
is the same thing with design.
To get to a good
design, you need
to go through this
crazy process where
you might end up
in places you never
thought you were going to.
And a lot of those
places might actually
be failures in the
traditional sense,
but they actually
move you forward
to get to a successful
design and product.
OK, so I'm going to talk
a little bit about me
and kind of how I followed my
white elephant opportunities
over the course of my career.
So this is me when I was a kid.
I'm the one in the very
interesting-looking dress.
I was the oldest of four kids
raised in southern California.
And my family was very Catholic
and fairly conservative.
And I had my first kind of
white elephant opportunity
when it comes to
my career happened
the summer after eighth grade.
So I was 13 years old.
It was around the
time of this picture.
And I went to Catholic
elementary school
and it ended in eighth grade.
It was K through 8.
And it was run by nuns.
And my friends and I, we
did not like the nuns.
And especially, we did
not like our principal.
And so we made a vow that
the day after we graduated,
we were going to do something.
And we were going to make
the world a better place
and fix all of the problems.
So we came up with this plan.
And it was actually
the night after we
graduated, we all
snuck out of our houses
and went to the school.
And we TPed the school.
Meaning that we
threw toilet paper
rolls all over the
trees and the buildings.
And the school also happened to
be a church, which-- because it
was Catholic.
It also happened to
have a rectory, which
is where the priest slept.
And somehow, while we were
throwing toilet paper,
somebody heard us and ran out.
And we saw them and we ran away.
And nobody else could be
identified in the dark
except for me
because of my hair.
So I got home.
And I snuck back in my house.
And I didn't know what
was going to happen.
And it was dark.
And I thought I was
like totally safe.
And I went up to my
bed, which I had,
by the way, set up to look
like a sleeping person.
And I opened the
door to my bedroom
and there was my mother
sitting on the bed.
And to this day,
she tells me God
told her that she had to
come up and check on me.
So anyways, I was caught.
So the end of the story,
which is the important part,
is I was grounded for the
entire summer that summer.
And I couldn't leave the house
except for a 10-minute walk.
And I couldn't watch TV.
And I couldn't use the phone.
So I was just bored
out of my mind.
And my dad was actually
a computer programmer.
I think I have a picture of him.
There he is.
So my dad was a programmer.
And he was brilliant.
And he knew how to build
computers and program them.
And all over the house, we had
these just parts of computers
and whole computers.
And that was back in the
day when you could just
build a computer pretty easily.
So that summer, I
learned about computers.
And by the end of the
summer, I could build them.
I could replace them.
I could fix them.
I had motherboards
all over my bedroom.
To this day, I still
have my little kit
with all my different
kinds of screws
because it reminds me of my dad.
But I learned all of that.
And I also learned
how to program.
So by the end of the
summer, I had written two
really cool programs.
One was called
Eliza, which was one
of the very first sort of
ways to model natural language
processing.
So it was this program that
you'd say like, how are you?
And it would go, how do you
feel about that question?
So I wrote one of those.
And I also wrote a game
called Sneaky Snake.
And it was awesome.
So that was kind of
this unexpected thing.
And I'd never been interested
in it before that time.
So that's my first
white elephant.
This is me and my dad
when I was in college.
And the next kind of white
elephant came along in college.
So I decided to pursue
electrical engineering.
Anyone in here electrical
engineering majors?
Oh, some of you.
Great.
Awesome.
I was lucky enough
to get a scholarship
to go to a really fabulous
school called Tufts University.
And they have a
school of engineering.
I was the only female
in my entire class.
And I started taking
electrical engineering.
And a couple things
happened there
that really kind of formed
my next white elephant
opportunity, that some
of them were pure luck.
For one thing, I did not
like electrical engineering.
And I didn't like the people
that were doing it, either.
There was all these guys
and they had these groups.
And they didn't want to
invite me into their groups.
And you know, they were sitting
around these [INAUDIBLE].
Anyways.
I was just like, I don't
think this is for me.
What do I do?
Secondly, Tufts had a new major
then called engineering design.
And so that was interesting.
And it was part of the
engineering school.
So I started taking
some classes in that.
And I thought it was so cool.
And then, third.
Tufts required that
every engineering student
took a class called Intro
to Engineering Design 101.
So I took that.
It was a big class.
It was like 100 kids
in it, students.
And they assigned
us a design problem.
It was kind of
our main challenge
for the semester, which
was design an oil change
kit for a car.
So I don't know
anything about oil.
I've never changed
a tire or oil.
I'm not into that stuff.
Don't like getting
my hands dirty.
But I thought, you know,
I'm going to rock this one.
I'm going to kill it.
And I was in Boston at Tufts.
My family was in California.
I didn't have any money to
fly home for Thanksgiving.
So I found myself alone
on campus for a whole week
and just walked around, and
crawled underneath cars,
and did all this research
on, how does this work?
Well, it turns out
there's this tank.
There's a little screw on
the bottom and you unscrew it
and the oil comes out, and then
you pour it back in the top.
It's pretty simple.
So what happened was most
of the students I knew,
they came up with a design
that was like, here's a bin.
And there's some
stuff like a funnel
and some gloves
and things in it.
And we just put
Saran wrap around it
and here was my design.
So I came up with
a design that was
like-- do you know
those Pringles
cans with the little pop up?
So I thought, well,
those are really cool.
So what if you shrunk one down
to this little size like this
and you put in it a big plastic
bag that could kind of compress
down that didn't melt?
And I researched
all the materials.
And you turned it upside
down and you could actually
screw it on to the oil tank.
Then when you wanted
to change the oil,
it would be super easy.
You could just pop the thing
off and the bag would fall down
and all the oil would go in it.
And you'd just throw it out
and put your new one on.
So I came up with this
design and I presented it.
And my professors just said,
oh my god, I have never
seen anything like that.
That was awesome.
And I thought, maybe
I'm a designer.
So that was really one of
my big white elephants.
OK.
So this story-- this is
actually a dialog box.
It's really old and
it looks really awful.
So the next thing I
did after college was I
worked for this
company called CLSI.
It was a library
systems company.
And I really wanted
to be an engineer,
but I couldn't get a job yet
as one, even though I knew how
to program.
So I got a job as a customer
support representative.
So I was answering the calls.
And people would call
in with their problems.
It was really hard.
And a great job, by the way.
I loved it because you find out
so much about what's going on.
So one day, a
librarian called in
and she said to me--
she was actually crying.
And it took me a while to figure
out what the heck is going on.
And then eventually,
she told me that she
was crying because she had an
error message up on her screen
that said a child has died.
So for those of you that might
not know what that means,
our product was written in Unix.
And in Unix, the way it
works is-- you guys all know.
You're all coders.
So you create a process
and it's basically
a child process has terminated.
So I knew what that meant
and I knew what that was.
But that really got me
going after that call.
And I thought, I'm
really interested in why.
Why would we put this
message up to our users?
And in the meantime,
I had been spending
a lot of time upstairs
with the programmers
because I really wanted
to be a programmer.
And I was this very
strange person to them
because it was like this little
blonde girl from California.
But I realized
that they actually
had an opening for somebody
to do front end development.
And nobody there wanted to do
that because that wasn't cool.
That's not the cool kind of
engineering, or it wasn't.
By the way, that's
completely a myth
because front end
engineering rocks.
It's awesome.
Anyway, so I came up
with this before-- I
wanted to become this thing.
So I came up with a whole set
of user interface guidelines.
And also patterns, what
we call today patterns
about how we should
be presenting
user interface to our users.
And how we should be
talking to our users.
And people were so
excited about that
that they actually allowed me
to move upstairs and become
an engineer.
And I was the only woman
engineer at that time there,
too.
So that was my first
kind of real awesome job.
So that was my second
white elephant opportunity.
Then after that,
I ended up working
at a number of amazing
tech companies.
So I worked for Symantec,
and then I went to Google.
So I actually worked at
Google about 10 years ago.
And that's when I had sort
of my next white elephant
opportunity, which you might
think was working at Google,
but it wasn't.
So back then,
about 10 years ago,
Google was a fabulous company
to work for, as it is today.
And it was already everybody
knew how wonderful it was.
People would come up to me
and say, oh, you're so lucky.
The problem was Google at
that time didn't really
care that much about design.
It wasn't really a thing.
I would say the
analogy would be it
was kind of like
having a strange hobby
that you do at night.
So people would be like,
oh, that's kind of cool.
But you know, let's
get back to work now.
So I found it
really challenging.
And I felt a little
bit like, I can't.
I don't know how I'm
going to grow here.
And then along came
another opportunity,
which was another
white elephant for me.
And it was at Yahoo.
And it was this huge role.
It was leading this
very large team of UX.
It was a user experience role.
It was taking a whole slew
of disparate products,
bringing them all together
into one platform,
redesigning the
whole thing, thinking
about a whole myriad
of different users.
It was big and it was hard.
And I initially was
like, I don't even
think I can interview
for this thing.
But I did.
And I ended up getting
an offer and I took it.
So this was another one of
those times where part of me
was saying, this is
way too much for you.
And you work at
this amazing place
and there's amazing food
and people and ideas.
What are you doing?
But I did.
I jumped on it and I took it.
And actually, that job turned
into one of the best things
that I've ever
done in my career.
I met so many amazing people.
We assembled this team, this
user experience team, of I
think about 80 to 90 people.
And we really rocked it.
We redesigned everything.
We came up with a
fabulous new platform.
It was great.
So again, something to jump on
that you might not think about
or you also might think I can't.
So, sorry, the picture
I just showed you
was me coming back
to Google today.
But I thought, wearing
my Noogler hat.
You guys all know
about Nooglers, right?
You have to wear a hat with
this little thing on the top.
After Yahoo, I ended up
moving for personal reasons
with my family to New York.
So when that happened--
and sometimes,
things happen where you're
in this great place,
but then something happens
out of your control.
We moved to New York.
And we live in a town right
near where my husband grew up
and it's fabulous.
But Yahoo doesn't
really do that.
They have a little
office in New York.
And it was kind of a
career-limiting move
to do that.
And I knew it when I did it.
So I started looking.
What else am I going to do?
What's my next
thing going to be?
And again, this
opportunity sort of
arose that really scared me,
which was chief experience
officer for Pearson Education.
So this is a C-level position,
a company with 40,000 employees.
A company that was very
traditional and very siloed.
And kind of in the
publishing world.
And they were, for
the very first time,
creating a role that would
bring people together
across the company and
bring all of the UXers
that they had together.
And also, build out more and
create a centralized team
across the company.
Again, this was a role
that I initially thought,
there is just no way.
First of all, yay, it's cool.
This is really great to have
a C-level position for a user
experience designer.
But I don't think I can do it.
But I was convinced by the
person that had told me
about it to interview.
And I showed up at the
interview and it was actually
the strangest and
scariest interview process
I've ever been to because it was
like being on a reality show.
And all of the
people interviewing,
we were all together in a room.
And then each time we'd
show up for the next round,
there'd be less of us.
Somehow, I got through it.
Somehow, I got the job.
And so I took the job.
I worked there for four years.
This is my leadership team.
So these are all the
folks that reported to me.
We had over 100 UXers.
And we built out
an amazing team.
And actually, I learned
so much, maybe even more
than I learned at Yahoo,
because I was in a place
where culturally
UX was not a thing.
Users were not that important.
Silos, and budgets, and P&Ls,
and sort of people's scope
of work was what
people focused on.
And I had to change that.
And actually, the way I did it
was by using the design sprint
method, with starting to do
these collaborative sprints
with collaborative
groups of people
from different silos that might
never have known each other
and put the user
front and center.
So we would bring students in.
And we would actually
come up with designs.
And we would test them
together, and then we
would iterate together.
And there is just no better
way to, a, learn about design.
But b, sort of bring
these teams together
and start realizing, oh,
that's why we're here.
We're here because of
this four-year-old kid
that can't read yet.
And we're trying to teach
them, that's why we're here.
And that's what our
products are for.
So it was a really amazing role.
And so that was, again, one of
my other white opportunities.
When the role
ended-- and it did.
And that was because
of a shift in a new CEO
and a new shift in focus.
And sometimes, what
happens is companies
decentralize and centralize
and decentralize.
You may have seen that.
So that's what happened.
I was presented with yet
another opportunity, which
was to come back to
Google, which I initially
thought-- I wasn't sure about.
But what had
happened in the years
before that is that Larry Page
had decided finally that design
was paramount to success.
And Google was doing
these amazing things.
Material design, if
you've heard of it,
is a fabulous new design
language that Google created.
Design sprints were
being used, finally,
which was so gratifying to me.
Because when I was at
Google the first time,
I was like design sprints.
Let's do them.
And everyone was
like, what is that?
So now we do them.
And we do them all the time.
Anyways, that all
brought me back
to being here at Google again.
And it's been just
truly amazing.
I've been here a
little over a year.
OK, now I'm going to talk
about my most important
white elephant opportunity.
So I have five children.
Four of them are back here,
along with my daughter's
friend.
My oldest is in college.
He's studying wildlife
and conservation.
And I never planned--
the back story here
is that I had never planned
to have kids, period.
When I was growing up--
and I don't know if I've
told my kids this before.
When I was growing
up, I was like, nope.
No kids.
No babysitting.
No, no, no, no.
So when I got married, my
husband was like, yeah,
I think I want a couple kids.
And I was like, I don't know.
I don't know about this.
And then eventually,
we decide, OK.
Maybe like one or maybe two.
And we have five.
So basically, this was a
white elephant opportunity.
It was very scary.
When I was pregnant
with my first one,
I thought, I don't
know if I can do this.
I don't even know if
I'm going to like this
or if I'm going
to be good at it.
And then after
that, it turns out
that we're extremely fertile.
More than 99% of people.
And we ended up with five.
But I have to say that
actually having five kids
has been the best experience
of my entire life, as crazy
that may sound.
It's actually really
helped me in my career.
It's grounded me.
When I worked at
Pearson, I've always
had a passion for education,
partially because I have kids
and I really care
about them learning.
And the way that they learn
is really important to me.
I was able to bring them into
my work for the first time.
And I actually brought
them in and used them
as subjects in user
experience testing.
But it's been really just
such a wonderful thing for me.
And obviously, it's the
most important thing
that I do as a mom.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
OK.
So I'm going to recap.
So white elephant
opportunity, just so
you can start thinking
about these for yourselves.
So first of all, it's an
opportunity that may arise.
It's not necessarily obvious.
So you need to look for them.
And it's going to
be unique to you.
It's not going to be
something that everyone's
going to jump on.
It may not align with your
perception of success.
So you might have this
line in your mind,
like I'm going to do
this, this, and this.
It may not be that.
It may be something wacky
that's kind of out there.
It may scare you.
And your initial response
may be, I couldn't do that.
I just couldn't do that.
There's like these other
people over here that
maybe could do it, but not me.
Don't think that way.
So take a risk.
And sometimes, they might fail.
I've had plenty of those, too.
And I didn't really talk
too much about them.
But sometimes you jump on
something and it fails.
And that's OK.
That's a learning
experience for you.
And that will move you
along to your next one.
And then, one other thing about
white elephant opportunities
is one way to sort
of generate more
is to find them and give
them to other people.
This is going to sound
a little bit strange,
but it's something I think
that I'm pretty good at.
And I didn't really
try to be good,
but I'm one of those
connector people
if you've read Malcolm
Gladwell's books.
I'm always keeping
my eyes out for stuff
and then I'll say, oh,
that's really cool.
And you over here
would be great at that.
Bing.
And sometimes, people
are like, go away.
But sometimes they say,
I've never thought of that.
And it's interesting
because I have
someone on my team, a woman
who I highly, highly respect.
She's the smartest person
I think I've ever met.
I was talking to last
week about this talk
and I mentioned this to her.
And she said, oh, yeah.
I know exactly what you mean.
It's just like what
you did for me.
And I was like, what
did I do for you?
And she said, well,
you kept pushing
me to consider this thing.
And the back story is
that she is actually
inventing an amazing new set
of research and guidelines
for Google that we've never
had before around ads.
And it's all based on
massive user research
studies and all kinds
of things that I
don't even fully understand.
And she's created this.
But she was a little
bit resistant at first
with the same kinds of things.
I don't know if I can do that.
Never thought about that before.
But she really is the only
person here who could do that.
So anyway, she saw
it that way and that
made me feel really good.
But when you do that,
things come back to you.
She's doing something
really incredible now.
There's all these
people that surround
that that I've never met and
now are part of my world.
And they're creating new
opportunities for maybe myself,
but my team members,
and also Google.
So it really does
come back to you.
So how do you find
these opportunities?
Know your passions.
Know what you're passionate
about and follow it.
Even if it's weird.
Even if it's strange and
you think, I don't know.
Follow those things.
When you start getting
really interested, which
for me is hard because I'm
interested in lots of things,
keep pursuing that.
And then, say yes.
So it's pretty simple, say yes.
Try it.
Do it.
And don't hold yourself back.
OK.
So I want to kind of
just close a little bit
with telling you a
little about today.
So first of all, you have some
white elephant opportunities
in this room.
You have a great opportunity
to meet some fabulous women,
and also to hear the panels
and the other speakers.
We have some great
people coming.
We have the panel about
creating opportunities
in tech, which is I
believe right after this.
And then we have the
Tech and Design Workshops
this afternoon.
If you're interested in
those, the design side,
you'll hear more about
sprints, which is great.
I don't know what the
tech people are doing,
but it will be
great, too, I'm sure.
And then in the
closing fireside chat,
it's Heather Rivera
and Minerva Tantoco,
who is the first CTO of
New York City and a woman.
And she's coming to speak to us.
So enjoy your day.
Meet people.
I'll be around.
Come talk to me.
Talk to my kids.
Torture them.
And thank you so
much for listening.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]